[Musique]
la caravelle vient de débarquer à luz
emma maroc
un contingent de nouveaux aventuriers
des loisirs organisés ils sont
aujourd'hui près d'un demi million à
pratiquer une telle formule de vacances
il y a dix ans ils étaient 2000
seulement et tout porte à croire que
bientôt ils seront 1 million à subir
ainsi cette cérémonie de l'accueil un
discours inaugural au plaisir fonde pour
chacun intronisé gentils membres gm les
lois de la société nouvelle le
tutoiement est de rigueur
la politique banny et l'argent en
principe supprimer une discipline
librement consenti fera le bonheur dans
l'oise yves thé et les gentils
organisateurs géo la ferons respecter
dans la bonne humeur
soixante pour cent des gens qui viennent
au club sont célibataires il y a trois
femmes pour elle
[Musique]
mais les élus ont-ils conscience d'être
des pionniers on citera un jour en
exemple dans les siècles le futur oui
pourquoi
par son ambiance pas son caractère
l'homme oui par le fait de coucher dans
des cases de se laver en groupe afin de
manger en groupe 1 ces jeux également
son organisation voit fait respectable
qui donne aux trouver cela tout ça très
bien oui qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
vie vous venez ici au club
elle est assez insignifiant du corps un
petit animal
très bien je vais le soleil et ça me
suis bien battu et je regarde les gens
la maison est ce que vous pas que la
gentille et ceux qui existent au club et
sincère oui pense que le moment tony
vous avez un colis du coup oui c'est
pour ces écoliers barça et c'est pour
les consommations au bar
c'est un autre délai formule du cloud
c'est à dire en l'abolition de l'argent
et qu'est ce que vous en pensez
d'abord ce formidable pour dépendre de
plus pour dépenser plus oui c'est ça que
je me le dis parce que ça coûte cher
aussi est là mais c'est beaucoup plus
gentil plus sympathiques ne vais pas les
gens avec ça qu'avec l'argent km
qu'est ce qu'on pensait d'eux des gens
qui vous accueillent ici ils sont très
charmant
notre charmant
léger aux garçons géo garçons ne sont
pas très intéressant dans ce que faisait
son beau garçon il pense que je me suis
fait pour est en général dispense note
des gentils organisateurs
il faut préciser et en quoi consiste
votre travail
eh bien je suis barmaid j'en suis à mon
sixième village parce que je fais
également les villages divers hiver
était sommes-nous passé pratiquement
toute l'année d'un village à l'autre
donc pratiquement toute l'année il faut
compter en moyenne louis 9 mois de
l'année et que penser votre travail est
ce que vous pensez que c'est un métier
[Musique]
c'est difficile à considérer cela comme
un métier c'est un métier oui en fait
pour moi c'est un peu envie d'un métier
puisque je suis barmen malgré tout c'est
un assez bon c'est malgré tout un métier
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas du tout une
situation d'avenir et en plus au club
on en vit au jour le jour c'est à dire
que par exemple la saison suivante
ils peuvent on peut me dire nous n'avons
plus besoin est bien évidemment j'en
pense beaucoup de bien et puisque ce
sont eux qui nous font vivre une des
règles du club c'est de ne pas parler
politique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
abolition de la politique en a glissé en
abolition poursuit c'est lorsqu'on se
trouve avec et si enfin lorsqu'on parle
de politique il faut faire ôter toi tais
toi tu sais on ne peut pas perdre mais
je pense que ça parce que c'est pas
simple at il du tout lorsque des parcs
du temple du ski nautique de la voile de
l'achat du numéro et comment vous faites
pour vous informer
je vais porter un petit transistor mais
on n'écoute rien alors lorsqu'il y
arrive les gens dallas dimanche alors
j'attends là bas aussi pour voir s'il ya
des jolies filles merci pour prend les
journaux à la recherche de voix journaux
puis quand ça
le temps-mort passé à ne rien faire et
il le temps de la réflexion
on en douterait si michel n'a porté sur
ce club
un regard critique pourquoi vous êtes
venu ici en vacances je me suis dit
tiens en fait une expérience à faire de
ce qu'ils vivent comme les autres je
suis venu au club président suisse comme
les autres c'est-à-dire pour essayer
d'être sportif moi qui ne suis pas du
tout pour essayer tatchou quoi est ce
que vous faites du sport
j'avais dit que je ferais je suis monté
deux fois sur le tour de ski je suis
tombé deux fois ça n'a pas amusé j'ai
pas recommencer et comment est ce que
vous voyez les gens qui viennent en
vacances au club les gens qui sont ici
au club sont des gens bien gentil qui
vient de passer trois semaines de
vacances ou un mois selon leurs moyens
est ce que vous trouvez que fera des
vacances
lancet
2e place certainement des vacances
qu'ils aiment je crois qu'en fait je
passe des vacances les vacances qui les
intéressent
moi je crois que j'ai fait cette
expérience j'ai eu la chance de tomber
sur des gens assez sympathique en fait
moi je me suis pas ennuyé je ne m'ennuie
pas mais il existe un esprit classique
ou trois jours on est intégré alors on
accepte cette intégration c'est à dire
qu'on fait comme les autres
c'est à dire que comme on est condamnés
pensez pas mal d'argent pour rire on rit
ou alors on essaye de se retrancher un
peu et avec ses amis de faire autre
chose que vous avez l'impression que les
gens se font tous incorporé ou la
majorité oui c'est à dire qu'ils le font
tous et ce qui est très amusant c'est
que vous avez des gens ici qui sont des
gens qui socialement ont une très belle
situation qui font pendant un mois les
choses qui ne passerait jamais à faire
ailleurs
je ne sais pas c'est peut-être de la
bêtise vous croyez que les gens se
sentent suffisamment incorpore pays
c'est à dire qui est toujours déjà
toujours délicieux qui voudrait l'être
plus mais enfin je crois que dans
l'ensemble les genres on ne peut pas
dire qu'ils aient oui doit se sentir
suffisamment incorporé parce que c'est
toujours dans la bonne mesure sa force
ça pousse pas quand même on vous demande
d'être en groupe mais on vous laisse
quand même une certaine indépendance et
à dire qu'on vous fait quand même pas
dormir dans un dortoir
vous dormez à 2 par case et que
pensez-vous des paillotes dans
lesquelles vous vivez elles sont d'abord
très inconfortable enfin ça c'est pas
très grave
elles ont surtout une grosse qualité
avec une sentinelle et le pensez vous de
leur style
pourquoi le site d'aÿ siens bon ça je ne
sais pas cette attitude
ça doit être la folie du temps sachent
quoi le soleil le sable l'eau si vous
pouvez dormir sur la plage ce serait
certainement encore plus club peut-être
est-ce que vous êtes venus ici plus pour
vous mêler à des gens que vous ne
côtoyez jamais pour faire en quelque
sorte une expérience ou pour mener une
vie naturelle plus naturel que ce que
vous vivez on habituellement non je
crois que la vie naturelle je la vis
quand je suis pas au club
non pas du tout peut-être si j'avais
vécu il ya 2000 ans j'aurais trouvé que
c'était naturellement notre époque je
trouve ça me dépasse et quand même les
paillotes et vous avez l'impression que
les gens apprécient c'est du masochisme
est ce que vous croyez que de vivre des
vacances de ce type change les gens et
vous change non parce que les gens
oublient très vite une fois revenu à
paris retrouvent leur intérieur leurs
voitures leurs occupations chez tous ces
sacs passer des vacances on va pour moi
c'est pas ça mais en fait pour eux c'est
peut-être ça mais vous passez les mêmes
vacances
moi je passe de très bonnes mauvaises
vacances est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les rapports sont
facilitées ici entre les gens le rapport
superficielle oui parce que tout le
monde se tutoie et sait comment vas tu
enfin en fait c'est pas c'est pas parce
qu'on se tutoie que les rapports sont
plus assez vite et on se dit bonjour au
revoir on passe trois semaines avec des
gens qu'on connaît absolument pas je
crois pas que les rapports soient
facilitées pas du tout oui c'est une
amabilité superficielle demander un
service réel à quelqu'un qui lui coûte
quelque chose il ya plus personne
comment expliquez vous que tous ces gens
se soumettent comme ça à ce que vous
appelez vous une incorporation
comment se fait-il qu'ils se
débarrassent se décharge de toute
responsabilité comme ça je crois que ce
qui a beaucoup d'importance pour eux
c'est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir dire quand
ils vont rentrer alors en fait ils
pourront dire qu'ils ont été au maroc
et ça ça a beaucoup d'importance vous
savez il ya beaucoup de gens qui
viennent ici comme il y avait comme ils
n'ont pas plus de choses que dans le
midi en fait mais ils sont allés au
maroc on vous dit que vous êtes au marin
quand vous direz vous êtes en turquie en
grèce ou en pologne veut le croire y est
presque
si on vous transporter les yeux bandés
d'orly ici on vous demande où tu es
vous auriez beaucoup de mal à dire je
suis au maroc
est ce que c'est une formule d'avenir
oui comme les supermarchés
madame vous avez fait 24 villages pouvez
vous me dire pourquoi vous choisissez
cette formule de vacances
et bien parce que je pense que c'est
l'évasion total c'est d'abord la joie de
vivre
le plein air les sports et pour moi et
mes enfants puisque je suis venu avec
des enfants c'est vraiment la formule
rêver quand j'arrive dans un village ya
le paysage il ya l'ambiance
il y a les jambes et puis je ne peux pas
vous dire pour moi c'est une étuve au
total c'est une évasion et vous croyez
que ce sentiment que vous ressentez si
on ne peut pas le peut se ressentir
quand on passe maintenant
certainement pas certainement pas parce
que ici avez vous vu déjà des j'aime
prendre un journal il y en a très peu
avez vous vu
un gm s'inquiéter de ce qui peut se
passer autour de lui non c'est fini
dès qu'on arrive au village vous mettez
le paréo le slip et le soutien-gorge un
pantalon pour le soir où une petite robe
pour les excursions puis c'est tout vous
aimeriez que la société française soit à
l'image de la société du club le 6 le
monde pouvait ces mets autant que l'on
sème dans le club
oui mon village il n'y a pas de vieux il
y aller les enfants il ya les jeunes il
ya les anciens jeunes dont je fais
partie voyez moi je n'ai pas les vieux
les anciens jeunes et tout le monde
s'amuse
[Musique]
on
e
parfois le maroc passe sur la plage tous
les jours en tout cas ils entrent par la
porte de service
ces marocains trim cours car dans un
pays où l'on chaume beaucoup un emploi
est vite perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien peu sont ceux des gentils membres
qui pensent à dire merci à leur
serviteur marocain personne d'ailleurs
ne leur dit rien est ce que ça vous gêne
d'être servis par les marocains n'ont
pas du tout comment vous voulez trouver
je ne sais pas je ne me prêterai
attention c'est ce que voulait tutoyer
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas je n'en
parle d'ailleurs parce que les eris non
ils font assez bien leur service et
c'est assez rare qu'on va faire est-ce
que vous pensez que visite un pays c'est
aussi connaître les gens de ce pays
certainement oui est-ce que vous avez
l'impression de les connaître
non pas du tout parce qu'ils sont assez
difficiles à approcher et d'autre part
on a un petit peu après jugé contre eux
c'est à dire quel est le préjugé que
vous avez contre eux c'est à dire on a
on n'a pas tellement confiance en un et
puis on ne comprend pas leur langue ce
qui est assez difficile mais pourquoi
vous n'avez pas tellement confiance en
nous est-ce que ça je ne sais pas c'est
instinctif vous les aimez pas beaucoup
je ne crois pas non je les aime où vous
est venu dans leur pays oui parce que je
pense que le maroc est un très beau pays
mais c'est le leur et wheeler yayi c'est
aussi eux qui l'ont fait bien sûr oui
mais seulement ça marche pas à l'instant
où vous pouvez très bien aimé apprendre
sans aimer
les personnes qui vivent
[Musique]
quand on revient des grands périples en
autocar à travers le maroc
on se déguise en sauvage des livres
d'image de notre enfance pour enfin le
soir
chanter et danser
[Musique]
girardin et lauda
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne dis pas
aïe
nous allons danser
[Musique]
c'est là dessus que nous avons quitté
alou c'est ma sur ce jeu du petit
marocain image un peu affligeant d'un
univers en définitive heureux
[Musique]